I wanted to start with bad boys for life
because it ended up being a huge hit and
I'm curious
well what were you hoping for in terms
of like worldwide box office because it
did a lot better than people anticipated
yet but hopefully we'll get there but it
was a phenomenal success we're so
excited by the guys made a terrific
movie will and Martin are just wonderful
together they really worked hard on the
script and during the shooting and it
certainly shows on the screen so it's
the number one picture of the year so
far
exactly um how much I heard after with
all the success that you guys might be
developing another one how much does the
studio want to do a fourth and you guys
well we had a great experience on the
first one both through the development
process with Tom Rothman and his team
and then through the editing process and
the filming process and then during the
the the fact that we preview process
went terrific and we put together along
with their help movie that's very
satisfying for the audience and we'd
like to do it again and I think they
would like us them and again we're
currently working on a draft for the
fourth week every time I talk to you I
ask you the same question
today is going to be no different what
do I need to do to get a national
treasure for it wow that's a Disney
question not me we're certainly working
on one for streaming and we're also
working on one for the big screen so
hopefully they'll both come together and
we'll bring you another national
treasure but they're both very active do
you think there's more of a chance of it
happening now with Disney plus I mean is
there a chance that it could be made for
that format or are you guys envisioning
it as the act well that would eventually
go to Disney once well we're one for
Disney Plus is is a much younger cast so
it's it's a different it's the same
concept but a young cast and one for
theatrical would be with it with the
same cast
can I ask how far along you are on both
versions well the the film version is
being written right now and the
television version is in process we have
I think a pilot script done and we have
the the episodes an outline of the
future episodes what do you think it
will take to get filming to begin again
have you had these conversations with
people I'm sure people are asking you
what is it going to take well I think
it's going to it's going to take that
hopefully the curve flattens we get out
of our homes that's that's the first
thing we got to do and then it's a
combination of the safeguards that we
put in and the NPA and all the studios
are working on guidelines on how to do
that and then they're working with the
insurance companies to hear how we
probably are we're insured and the other
issue is going to be testing
hopefully the I read an article just
recently that they have saliva testing
which is as accurate as a swab testing
so even even more accurate so we'll have
to test people where they come up to
check their temperatures there are a lot
of social distancing a lot of people
will be working from the homes or from
the remote offices we'll figure out a
way to do it we always do switching into
a few other things you've produced I
mean too many movies for me to mention
I'm curious did you ever get the
directing bug was it something that you
ever thought about doing yeah for a
minute but I don't have the attention
span to do that you know I have to have
multiple things going all the time
that's what keeps me going but you know
it's your Peter Principle you know do
what you do do what you know how to do
best and fortunately I've been pretty
good at what I'm doing yeah I would say
if you could produce if you could get
something greenlit tomorrow that has
never been able to get a green light
what would that project be in Y well we
have a number of things that we're
working on that we'd like to get
greenlit so I don't want to point in one
because there there's a bunch of them
and we're very excited about some of the
new projects that we have coming up my
concept is a great book have you ever
would you ever consider doing like a
documentary about your belay
shipped on what went on back then uh not
really
I think first of all I never having read
I concept before what people told me
about it there's a lot of inaccuracies
in it so that's you know a lot of the
people that that talked to the
journalists or the writer I didn't check
with us first so we certainly would have
would have guided in a different way
you've made so many iconic films and I
would have imagined that there's great
stories that went on making these movies
have you ever thought about doing like a
fictionalized version of the making of
one of these films or events from your
life because I can only imagine the
stories well there are a lot of great
stories I wish I could remember them all
but but I don't think that's that's what
I would want to do I never look back on
you look back to learn from the past and
try to keep moving forward he create
better content than we've made before I
believe it's at the end of the rock
Nicolas Cage gets away with some
valuable microfilm about the JFK
assassination that was obviously a huge
hit was there ever talked about doing a
sequel to that did that ever come close
no that's that's never come in in our
conversation it might have very early on
but nothing recently and obviously the
Pirates of the Caribbean franchise is
massive
I know that they're always looking to do
another one is there can you give an
update as to the status of another
pirates movie yeah we're working on a
draft right now and hopefully we'll get
it shortly and give it to Disney and
hopefully they'll like it
we don't know we've been working on it
for a little bit is it like a spin-off
of the Pirates that we know or is it
another one for John well the one where
we're developing right now we're not
sure quite what Johnny's role is going
to be so we'll have to see I love
everything I've seen on Top Gun mac-like
absolutely loved visuals look
unbelievable what can you tease people
about the movie I mean obviously you
must see it I've seen a finished version
or close to a finish yeah we're we're in
the editing process and doing music the
and demikhov's and stopped us tom is
working everyday on it besides getting
ready to shoot Mission Impossible it's
it's really exciting it's the aerial
stuff I've never seen anything like it
the performance is great young actors
general Connolly is amazing we're really
thrilled you know we're really happy
that we have such an amazing movie on
our hands can you tease a little bit
about the story well I think what's out
there is is kind of what we want to have
the public know right now teas more as
we get closer to released it um I was
very impressed but you and Aang did with
the high frame rate on Gemini man and
the technology that it took to bring
that film to life can you sort of talk
about how technology has influenced how
you are going to make movies in the
future or if there's any new
technological innovations seen that you
want to apply to what you guys are doing
well every day there's new things that
are coming up for us to use to wise and
that comes down to our our directors and
our digital effects people who
constantly explore new ways to bring
great storytelling to the big screen and
we're kind of lucky right now that
emailing it through this pandemic there
ways we can build things that look
spectacular not even with the outdoors
so that's really helpful for all of us
uh I mentioned earlier you have a whole
bunch of things in development and
Bruckheimer films what's what's getting
ready to pop over there or besides high
town that you're excited for fans to
know about well we have a bunch of
pilots that we're hopefully getting
gonna get made once this thing is over
and you know you're excited about all
your projects that you hope to get Nate
and some of them rise to the top and
some of them never make it but we we
work hard until we get get a green light
on all of them are you still involved
with Wild Bunch and Mel Gibson we are we
are we're very engaged on that we hope
to get that made shortly to one since
this kind of virus disappears grow up
late heard through the grapevine that
Mel might have been doing some location
scout for the movie which leads me to
believe that it was that it's far along
that is true he did he did some location
scouting fortunately for us before the
pandemic hit us and I hope that we get
back up to speed as soon as they lift us
out of this home home lockdown
I think Mel is a ridiculously talented
director I mean he gets credit but I
don't think enough credit for what he's
been able to do can you sort of talk
about what it's like to work with him
developing a project and if he was
impressed you about working he's so
smart he's such a great storyteller he's
a terrific writer he did a lot of
writing on on the movie he's got such
great insight into character and story
and he also is a brilliant director I
mean and he's a fun guy he's a really
funny guy to work with
he's very very very collaborative and
it's just been a great experience for me
to be able to be with the director of
that caliber and you know a lot of
actors are dying to be to work with him
and we're trying to put together a great
cast
I got a wrap up I'm just gonna say thank
you so much please stay safe healthy and
thank you so much for your time
do the same thing thanks for being here
with us I really appreciate it